small steps towards a new normal
the government's unlocking road maps
still on track
from monday the 12th of april we will
move to step
two of our road map reopening
shops gyms zoos holiday campsites
personal care services like hairdressers
and of course
beer gardens and outdoor hospitality of
all kinds
we see nothing in the present data
that makes us think that we will have to
deviate
from that roadmap but and you know i'm
going to say this
we can't be complacent we can see the
waves of sickness
afflicting other countries freedom's
being returned but with new conditions
and big unknowns no guarantees
international travel will be permitted
after may the 17th
and you could be asked to show a clovid
free certificate
to go to a concert or even the pub and
to support all of that
twice weekly covered tests you can get
these tests from your pharmacies from
pharmacies
or your local test site you can even
order them on gov dot uk and get home
deliveries
it looks like you're asking ours to have
twice a weekly testing
and it's likely that we'll have to carry
around some form
of covert certification is that your
vision now for what
freedom looks like for all of us and how
long are we going to actually have to
live like this
if things continue to go well i do think
that
for many people in many ways life will
begin to get back to you know at least
some semblance of normality but
uh you know we're still somewhere off
there we've got to be guided by the data
and i think that a world in which we
continue to have
um testing uh is not going to be
uh too onerous and to professor witte
chile has one of the world's fastest
vaccination rates
but it's also just had to close its
borders
to slow the spread of covid and stop the
influx
of new variants from abroad is there
anything we can learn from the chile
experience
in chile as you say significant
remarkable effort by the chilean
people to vaccinate to vaccinate at a
high level but they have not had quite
the same effect now
is this due to the vaccines used is this
due to
the timing of when things have actually
been rolled out
is it due to particular interactions
with other variants
we don't yet know the assumption that
just you vaccinate lots of people when
the problem goes away
i think chile is quite a good kind of
corrective to that
chile a reminder that mass vaccination
might not be our panacea
government documents out today say
stopping the influx of new variants is
still
a very important priority for people in
south london that's their priority too
even if that does threaten summer
holidays because some variants are
coming from abroad
it's difficult so i'm a bit i think they
should hesitate on that and take it
slowly we're in our own little bubble
here and
we have to watch what's happening
elsewhere when it comes to the borders
i think they should still be contained i
think that's what we should have done
originally and i feel that we should
probably still be doing that for a while
yet slowly
moving towards a new normal but what
freedom will look like after a year of
this pandemic
is shifting the dates of the road map
are set
the contours of our destination are not
rigby sky news westminster